hey everybody it's Wednesday also April
Fool's Day we're not gonna do that's why
I'm here we're here every day though it
would have been funnier if you weren't
she then to me here [ __ ] yeah double up
on that okay yeah so that sounded dirty
but yeah sorry if you hear something in
the background it's just like the long
crew was out there outside I think they
they were like right around the front of
the house earlier and I could like hear
about my office window like super loud
but I think they've finished that right
now yeah but let's see what can we talk
about um oh I wanted to say last night
this was the weirdest [ __ ] thing ever
it wasn't even cloudy or anything last
night we're gonna 10:30 or 11 o'clock
when we finished watching the movies
that we were reviewed for about natio
yeah um all of a sudden we had this like
freak rainstorm yeah came out of nowhere
and I didn't even realize it was so loud
that at first I didn't realize it was
rain I thought it was a tornado and like
the rain was that it was like horizontal
it was like like against it was like a
[ __ ] hurricane oh yeah and she just
like ran over there because she's not
scared of things really but she's just
like ran over there and got into the
curtains so she could look out the
sliding glass door yeah and then she was
just like looking at that like it was
like everything was [ __ ] blowing
around and then when I went on the trail
this morning it looks like it's a big
[ __ ] mess out there
branches a mini hurricane leaves and
[ __ ] like that everywhere crazy it was
nice and cool out this morning though
yeah it's still cool out there
oh is it was like 71 70 degrees yeah
this morning I went outside I was like
whoa yeah oh my cuz yesterday it was
like so [ __ ] humid and Yaqui what's
on list um yeah I wanted to mention that
oh I also want to mention I got a um an
email today I don't know if like how you
know relevant this is to everybody but
you know when I was talking about my
board games and stuff like that before
and I have like three of them up I've
still been working on other ones and
like I said by the end of this year I
kind of want to have like a whole
website up because I have a whole bunch
of other games that I have done that I
have ready that I haven't uploaded yet
but I got a um email from game crafter
today and they are still like remaining
open in the sense that they still
they're still like taking orders and
they still
you know customer service and stuff
stuff like that but they're all working
from home
they're just suspending they had to
close like they're manufacturing factory
they like the thing that makes all the
games you know for coronavirus so they
didn't want all their workers to get
sick so they had to close it down so
they're actually closing down stuff
until April 24th or until further notice
they said we're still taking orders and
[ __ ] like that so if you still want to
order something then do it but just keep
in mind that you probably won't get it
for a few months like until everything
comes back online but you know I've been
working on another game like I said I've
[ __ ] done I'm finished I've been working
on one that's based on like ancient
Egypt mythology like him but I call it
curse of never Kalla I haven't decided
yet
but I've got like most of the board done
and some of the other [ __ ] so we'll see
how that goes but I have a bunch of
other ones designed as well also like I
said my goal was this week to start
working on faceless villain millennium
or faceless villain for whatever the
[ __ ] I'm gonna call it I don't I don't
know yet and like I said I've made I'm
doing the outline for the first chapter
which is gonna be unsolved murders from
the year 2000 and there are so many that
I'm gonna have to like take a bunch out
I mean you know what I mean because it's
a thing where I feel bad like leaving
ones out but there's so many that
there's not that many details about them
and it's like it's just like mentioning
it but then there's nothing there right
so then it's like I'm kind of have a
thing where it's like well do I even
want to mention it because it's like not
so much so I don't know I'm either gonna
try what I wanted to try to do is maybe
limit it to like 12 cases per chapter or
something like that or just ones that
had at least like three articles about
them or something like that it's gotta
be enough there to write about you know
I mean that's what I mean it's like you
know I still want it to be like I said I
feel shitty like leaving some murders
out because it seems like Oh once some
matter more than the others but then in
some ways like a lot of murders they
don't really have much reporting about
them because like I said every state has
well pretty much every state has a
database of like all their cold cases
all their unsolved murders so I've been
trolling through all of those and the
vast majority of them are basically just
like hey this person was found dead in
there
we don't know who the [ __ ] did it if you
have any information call us that's
pretty much like all that's there
another thing is is that you know the
cops have the information but they're
not gonna put it out yeah just because
it you know cuz these cases are old but
they're not that old so a lot of times
seeing on the menu right in about a case
and the details in me very sparse but
there's a lot more known about that case
just to keep the investigative the
investigative techniques of the police
is not to release that information yeah
so that's the problem so in some ways I
get it it's easier to write about older
ones right yeah there's more there
because there's more there and they're
like you know probably most of the
suspects are dead at this point so it's
like it doesn't really matter now it's
like I'm so much reading something the
other day to that and I think I
mentioned this maybe in like the
foreword of one of my last books that it
you would think that with better
investigative techniques that more
murders would get solved nowadays the
weird no it's not it's less there like
now even though there are in the
aggregate less murders like crime has
been going down like since the 90s
with little bobbles here and there but
in general like the murder rate has been
going down but they're like even with
that in mind there's still less of them
solved than there was like a long time
ago which to me seems very weird because
now they have DNA and everything I I'm
not sure why that is exactly well a lot
of people will put a lot of you know
they'll place a lot of weight on like
technology will be able to solve this
with technology we have the weapon we
have the bullet we'll figure out you
know I mean who had this gun we have the
serial numbers on it we'll just look up
the damn serial numbers ain't none of
that true none of it true for instance
there were like millions of little
draven 25s made they all had serial
numbers on them you could scratch a
serial number off of it and the guy
would say oh they'll never know you know
they'll never be able to trace this gun
yeah you can drop acids on there when
they punch for those numbers it'll make
that number clear even though you filed
it off you'll still be able to see it
because there's more molecular density
of where they plunge to the damn numbers
yeah okay so you say you would think
well they had the number now I'll [ __ ]
find
who had the gun well you run the numbers
on the gun and Ravin arms said yeah that
one we made that one 20 20 years ago and
we sold it to this distributor something
or other and you go ask him and they go
to that distributor and go yeah we sold
that to California well they don't know
how many pans yeah and then I saw the
last time this thing was [ __ ] sold
legally it was sold to [ __ ] John
Brown 20 years ago
yeah find him oh and then they find him
hey John what did you do with that where
were you on the night he what are you
talking about this meat Raven maybe this
Raven arms pistol oh I sold that two
weeks after I bought it yeah I sold it
to a friend of mine or got stolen or as
well there could be a million oh they
started going through it and they find
out this [ __ ] man this thing has changed
it changed hands to three hundred damn
people the past 20 years yeah that's my
me and I did read that I'll never find
out well that the more that a murder is
committed with a gun the more likely you
are to get away with it obviously
because it's like much easier yeah
because you know it obviously strangling
somebody or you know stabbing them or
something leaves a lot more DNA at once
and then they think that well they'll be
able to see the rifling marks on the
bullet boy that's a laugh they'll be
able to find out how many grooves and
how many lands were in the rifling which
might narrow it down to the brand of the
gun but the actual exact little bucking
little scrapes and the things that try
to line it up that's [ __ ] because
those little scratches inside that
barrel are changing every every time you
you [ __ ] shoot the pistol yeah
they'll slowly change you know what I
mean like it what deep the little micro
grooves inside that that are being left
behind on those boats changes every 20
shots make it unrecognizable that's just
something that they using a courtroom to
sell some [ __ ] you know I mean when they
have the pistol and they have they have
the bullet and they have the body and
they have the suspect maybe they can
somehow find and find a place where a
little segment of that bullet Myton
might match up with a couple of
scratches inside of yeah inside of a
barrel that doesn't mean that those
scratches inside the barrel made those
lines on that bullet though but I mean
does it in that I feel like if you are
if you have
a bunch of other clues like leading
toward the suspect and that's way
another day yeah then okay it's the
whole weight of the case but if that's
but if that's just one thing that's not
enough I mean that's almost kind of like
saying hey this is the same handwriting
as the case yeah which there is some
truth to that but it's a very like
handwriting analysis in general is a
very like nebulous yeah kind of art to
it yes so the same thing with trying to
piece together yes well that came out of
what piss you really a lot yeah you know
a lot of circumstantial evidence that
gathers into like one thing and an
awesome lawyer that can lies ass off
that always especially if you got it
where your lawyer a lot a million dollar
lawyer because that million dollar
lawyer will take ten thousand dollars
into how bribe that judge but yeah so I
was reading that the way that um like a
lot fewer murders are solved nowadays
which seems counterintuitive I was also
like [ __ ] I was watching this thing
the other day where they were talking
because I watched like a lot of true
crime stuff obviously because it's a big
interest that I have some people were
saying they were talking about why the
six like late 60s 70s 80s were like the
heyday of the serial killer and they
were wondering whether the same thing
might happen again like 10 15 years down
the line when this particular generation
gets to be into their 20s that if the
same thing will happen because they were
saying stuff like the reason I mean
there's a lot of reasons obviously why
the 70s and the 80s I think the peak was
in 87 for serial killings but um you
know it's been going down ever since
then it's a very very tiny you know
fragment of you know the murders that
are committed but they thought that it
might have something to do not only with
you know society as a whole becoming
more mobile people moving around more
people doing you know high-risk
behaviors like hitchhiking and stuff
which obviously is a factor they were
also wondering too whether they said now
these were kids that grew up and their
fathers and grandfathers had been
you know in World War 1 World War two
and they were wondering if like when
their dads and you know grandparents
came back from these wars that had seen
these like horrible things and
everything if it had some kind of impact
on the way that the children grew up
like maybe their dads were kind of like
more emotionally distant or more
physically abusive or something like
that that would contribute you know and
like I said there's a zillion other
factors and there's no doubt there's not
sure but they're there just wondering if
that might have been you know something
like a factor in why there were so many
serial killers around that period I
think because a lot of serial killers do
seem to have like real emotionally
distant parents or physically or
mentally abusive fathers I think it'd be
more likely with some kind of likely to
something inherited like epigenetics
something like that well I do think that
there's a genetic component sure but I
definitely think that it's a combination
of the two things in epigenetics you
know in epigenetics theoretically what
you're talking about is that the stress
that a father or the mother might be
going through can somehow impact an
unborn child yeah you know I mean
they're saying that maybe a mother who
was under a lot of stress that's when
she's just eating a kid the Gina the
genome of the child could be slightly
modified so it's born with a higher sets
with a higher maybe um over the higher
propensity towards aggression or higher
propensity towards like histrionic
behavior that kind of [ __ ] well that is
Bill well because stress does physically
affect your body by later releasing
cortisol and things like that and sure
it could like have some kind of impact
like I said I don't think that you know
people that turn out to be serial
killers I don't think it's entirely
genetic I don't know how I knew that
[ __ ] anyway though I got my own theory
what for leaded gasoline I think had
something to do with it well done and
I'm not saying that there but that
wasn't a factor because it might have
been and another thing I think it was is
that it was on the surface of the
society that time was very sexually
repressive yeah and repressed so young
people did not grow up with too much
okay what do you call it like an
understanding of a normal sexual
behavior yeah so what ends up happening
is used
getting perversions yeah and if the kid
isn't popular enough to date and find a
you know I mean date remember you know
like girls or whatever he might get
pissed off and become what you'd called
a like an in cell yeah and then he's a
pervert and in cell which might you
start coming up with guys to have these
weird BDSM type [ __ ] perverted
fetishes yeah because look at like BTK
and stuff like right and it's not
something and then there's no place to
like there's no there's no scene to
where they can go out and [ __ ] you
know man go to a photos indulge and get
out of system they don't have that so
he's holding this in as like a dark
secret he's yeah it becomes like comes
malignant and yes [ __ ] I'm gonna grab
that girl a torturer yeah I definitely
think that's a big that's what I think
it is that's why I think that cuz you
know I could see whether there's what
you would call a day a rape culture yeah
well I mean I could see what you know
what the authors were saying it's like
oh you know could it happen again
you know when the this current
generation gets to a certain age but I
don't think that's gonna be the case
because like you said I think that there
was a large factor of like like all of
this stuff being sexually or people
feeling like you know I have this
particular fetish or I have this
particular sexual proclivity and I'm the
only one in the world and I'm really
weird and it just kind of like was like
a self-loathing kind of feedback loop
and I don't really think that people
have that anymore because I have yeah
people have like a better understanding
that's [ __ ] killing a lot of that yeah
of sexuality and it's like you know that
you know if you're indulging in a
healthy way with consenting people and
stuff it's like you can find a community
of people even if it's just online or a
person who's who's kind of [ __ ] up
that way can go online and read about
this [ __ ] and then they can find out
they can figure out on the room kind of
what it is they're going through and why
this is not a good path to go through
and what this means and they could might
be able to dissolve it without even
having to talk to anybody
yeah because you can see that you're not
the edition that there were other people
that had that God do is just look at
places in the developing world where
they have real restrictive cultures and
religions and stuff they tend to [ __ ]
do weird [ __ ]
you know I mean because there's lots of
single males that will never
produce they won't be able to find women
because they're there in societies where
one guy has three or four women you know
I mean if you're low income you can't
buy a wife
those dudes end up lashing out they go
[ __ ] berserk that's what you know
they exhibit that same kind of behavior
you know I mean rape culture is [ __ ]
yeah
the modern description of that even
though I think that's a misnomer what it
is is you have involuntarily celibate
men malfunctioning it's really a better
way kind of kind of like a form of
insanity and ignorance happened in the
same with superstitions and [ __ ]
superstitions about sex yeah yeah well
I'm like I said we've seen that with
even a lot of the serial killers we come
a particularly BTK because I'm waiting
about him right now whereas you could
tell that even though he had a fairly
normal childhood he had these you know
he had what is today considered a pretty
normal you know sexual fetish he was
into BDSM and stuff like that but he was
in a society that wouldn't allow right
it was like something that wasn't really
considered you know normal or something
so it just became like got worse it
metastasized yeah so I definitely think
that was kind of his friend man he
couldn't get it out of his system so it
just got more deeply ingrained into him
over time yeah yeah I mean so it wasn't
just some flight of fancy yeah yeah the
key became his sexual identity yeah you
know but yeah it was it was an
interesting thing anyway they never want
to get to [ __ ] you don't ever want to
go down too far any kind of rabbit hole
you want to be moderate in everything
yeah these dudes are not moderate yeah
you just gotta kind of like chill the
[ __ ] out chill the [ __ ] out and like
keep kind of fun stop taking [ __ ] so
seriously he [ __ ] you I think old you
know what I mean
it's you well it's good sometimes to
like kind of it you know especially in
like the [ __ ] crazy ash times we're
living in now it's kind of good
sometimes to just kind of like get
outside yourself and look at the damn
big picture look at the big picture and
also kind of like unplugged for a little
while it's like it's okay if you don't
want to like sit there and watch [ __ ]
about the [ __ ] coronavirus for a 24/7
and like
all [ __ ] stressed out and worried
about it it's like man go eat a donut
and watch some [ __ ] mst3k or
something like that it's just like it's
okay to not be like that I was thinking
about it earlier because I was thinking
you know before eating any of this like
[ __ ] pandemic should happen back in
the day when I used to like hang out
with my grandma a lot you know when I
was living with my grandmother she was
terrified terrified of hurricanes right
so every time we had hurricane season
and there was a hurricane that developed
you know and they developed way out in
the Atlantic and every time that would
happen she would wig the [ __ ] out
because she was sure that it was gonna
hit us and she grandma was the same for
days and days and days she would just
watch nothing but the Weather Channel
yeah and just like watch as it was
approaching and then she watch all the
models it's like it might come in and
I'm like look if you if you got bottled
water in your house you got flashlights
and batteries and [ __ ] like that
it's like there's nothing you can do
sitting there watching it worrying about
it
help anything as long as you've taken
precautions that is literally all you
can do you can't control it I know
people have this thing where they want
to control everything and I think that's
been the whole thing with like the
pandemic with everybody just rushing out
of buying everything in sight because
they feel like that's all they can do to
like maintain some kind of modicum of
control over things even though you're
not really but I kind of feel like
because you know staying home and not
doing anything which is what they're
telling everybody to do that's making
that stress in people out because they
people like to feel like they have some
kind of control over their life but I
mean you don't say always look at the
[ __ ] just like chill out me I see this
kind of stuff and I don't really feel
any stress to me it's just I thrive in
this kind of stuff but that was my
upbringing
you got a made [ __ ] the first things
I did you know I came up in a military
school and then the very first things I
did pretty much as an adult is go to war
you know in the infantry so [ __ ]
disaster and apocalypses I was just
[ __ ] that's candy to me you know but
also you know I was really really at one
with [ __ ] dying and other people
dying and living and dying and kill or
be killed and it's just kind of I've
just kind of resigned myself
to that fate we all eventually die
anyway so I don't feel the kind of
stress I think that a lot and there's a
lot of you out there especially you
military guys know exactly what I'm
talking about stress can be very good
it's very easy for you yeah here's some
of it there are certain kinds of
stresses that are very good these are
normal stresses okay from my point of
view because for me the stress of
survival is normal a lot of people
aren't aren't used to that they're
worried about paychecks as [ __ ] I was
worried about [ __ ] bullets you know
crap like that all right this is normal
stress I was kind of built to [ __ ]
deal with this I can deal with this you
know I meant because it's something I
can grab on with my hands I had a harder
time with [ __ ] jobs and paying bills
and [ __ ] and [ __ ] dealing with banks
cuz that's like a that's not a concrete
problem it's more of a it's a notional
problem you know I mean it in some ways
like I I don't know I don't enjoy that
obviously but I tend to only it and I
think that this is just as I've gotten
older and kind of like chilled out some
I still get really stressed out but I
tend to only get stressed out about [ __ ]
I have control over like oh my god I
don't have enough money to you know pay
my bills this month I need to like find
another gig I need to do this that so I
stress out about that [ __ ] like this
like hurricanes or [ __ ] you know
pandemics or whatever I don't stress out
about that because I can't do anything
about it nothing I do is gonna change
the course of the hurricane or yeah you
know change I get the disease or not you
could say we're both resigned but
resigned in different ways for different
reasons and she can't do anything about
it and I'm saying I can't do something
about it that's just what I'm just
saying I can't do anything about a dis
experience before I can live outside for
[ __ ] months months I can ride horses
I can [ __ ] make [ __ ] I can catch fish
you know what I mean that I can meet
camps I've done it that was just a part
of it
so if civilization were to [ __ ]
disappear I'd go mad max quick and would
be comfortable yeah and I can show you
how to do it well then well yeah in a
very low stress of life well really yeah
it didn't come like the Indians you
become like a hundred gatherer it's so
much harder to be a damn farmer it's a
lot harder
well yeah cuz now you have to tell soil
you know man yeah it's a lot it's a lot
more work yeah but if you're just in the
hunter-gatherer mode a lot of time just
walking and sleeping you know putting
trot lines yeah I can make trial long as
you're by the [ __ ] Y of water you can
hey you have food and like I said I
don't care yeah and they're in there
easy to catch and you know [ __ ] once
everybody dies off and it's just cool
people left I'm things like you know
horses might make a comeback if it goes
back to the here's nothing if we were to
lose the energy sector people tell all
would have windmills and solar that's
[ __ ] fantasy you would never be able
to run this society this civilization as
it is now using wind and solar the
energy requirements the energy demands
are too great if the files if the fuel
companies and the oil companies went out
of business real quickly we view back to
the 1880s and when you're in the 1880s
you can't support a population that's
big so that means ten hundreds and
millions of people would die quickly
you wouldn't feed them all and you can't
run a modern city without without
electricity and that's where that
electricity is coming from mostly coal
you know and we don't have enough
nuclear power plants they should have
done something about that because you
can use nuclear people like well that
nuclear waste you can send nuclear waste
into space you can send it down a
mineshaft where it came from where
there's all kinds of [ __ ] uranium
down there and she goes where do you
think you Ray Neum came from it's a
natural element but all that waste you
can put it down to the core the earth
down in the mantle you never notice it
and we're you know if you want to send
it out of space as heavy but anyway
people worrying too much this is not a
[ __ ] extinction level event unless
these people [ __ ] wig out make it one
it's not what I worry about is that
people were gonna do it'd be like a
cellphone on what I'm saying is worried
about that I can't do anything about it
I'm just saying it's kind of like a
hurricane when it's coming towards you
it's either gonna hit you or it's not
you worrying about it is not gonna do a
goddamn thing to prevent that you were
just a tiny little person an
insignificant person and it doesn't
matter so the same thing is that you
know with the pandemic even though it's
not
exactly like a hurricane it's kind of
like that because it's like a force of
nature and it's like you can take
precautions just like you can't afford
can't is coming you can like stay in
your house you can like wash your hands
you like you know minimize your contact
with people but that's pretty much all
you can do I mean you can't control
whether you get it or not really this
pandemic had it hit and we did nothing
the models say about 2 million 2.4
million people would have died most of
them old people and people that have
medical conditions and yep
that's not that many when you really
kind of think about it in the big
picture but they would have all died
within a few weeks of time now huge
[ __ ] problem well yeah every day
about probably million people probably
died and I say today how much [ __ ] how
many people you think died a day gotta
be enough it's got double think it's in
matters of thousands probably died just
maybe I mean that'll cause I don't know
off yeah just off natural cause but um
no I think they said 2.4 million would
maximum wouldn't which I mean that's a
lot that's a lot actually in a short
period of time so they had to do
something all right
yeah at minimum they were saying that
you know if we had done nothing it would
have been I think they said 1.4 million
that's still a lot it is so they had to
do something but I'm telling you they're
not gonna they're not gonna shut down
society unless society collapse and
[ __ ] everything go bad max on the
corner behind quarantines well like I
said you can absorb those yes because
more young people would die of course
their formalization almost most morning
you have like a 70% reduction of the
population in a couple years I'm just
saying that you went back to 1800s which
that's what would happen
most people would die they don't have
the skill sets I mean to keep it all in
perspective though it's like you know
2.5 million people is a lot in a short
period of time but Spanish flu which we
talked about our pandemic show that
killed what 50 million
it was like a [ __ ] ton more yeah but the
modern house and the modern people say
well they didn't have electricity back
in the 1800s to have big cities yeah but
it was very different back then those
cities had horses and they had a means
to run without really dirty and on Santa
they were dirty mention but every house
had like a coal burning stove
wood-burning stove where if you had wood
you could keep it warm in the winter you
could also cook your food you know
modern apartments don't have that so
you'd say well we need to give everybody
damn stove so it takes time to make all
that [ __ ] and if you don't have
electricity you can't run an industry to
make all that stuff things start
breaking down you know this society
isn't set up to make a rapid backwards
transition from 2020 back to 1820 in a
year it wouldn't make it thought people
would die they didn't have the proper
education for that or the skill set you
know yeah but like I said I don't think
we're looking at a city they wouldn't
allow it to happen
because they wouldn't allow it to happen
because you know there's a continuing
continuance of governments program there
there are whole parts of the government
in the military and government gets
excited I think they're inside NORAD
right now that's what I heard inside of
a damn Mountain they will not allow the
civilization to totally collapsed they
just won't yeah like I said that's not
not worried that anywhere about either
but like we're stressing they're
stressing because they're not they're
not getting any money well that's what I
mean I would be stressed out to you oh
sure sure you know who's even more
stressed out than us Mexico I got word
from Mexico they're not getting anything
and there's a bunch of [ __ ] they're not
showing on TV they're they're looting
all the damn stores for food and the
Mexican army sits there and watches it
because they know that there's nothing
to do yeah
all right wealthy and there's no plan
for any kind of stimulus package for the
Mexican people it's very very [ __ ]
dangerous you know who I'm talking about
he's very worried yeah and the only
thing they can do is just barricade
themselves in their house with their
beans of ricin and their water filters
and hope everything's okay yeah if that
kind of economy collapses and at that
that their currency collapses they're
[ __ ] and they don't have strategic
reserves of oil like we do so that could
be very dangerous no power yeah and they
would be able to buy new oil in the
[ __ ] market because they didn't have
any Monday could just be taking it for
an date I got
if it's possible to send them foreign
oil aid yeah they just not gonna let
this go that far lay to put everybody to
work soon
mark my words Nostradamus speaks notice
what Thomas speaks the man who saw
tomorrow and make a whole [ __ ] India
see the man who saw tomorrow but not
really any farther than George Carlin
George Carlin I remember made a joke
about that he's like said some about
some invention that he was thinking
about that was like really lame and then
he's like look I'm a visionary I can see
a head he's like problem is it's only
about a couple of hours yeah but yeah so
anyway let's uh around it that's what I
mean it's like I let this go too far
just you know I know everybody's in a
different situation and it's easy for us
to sit here and say hey don't worry
about it but it's like this has taken me
47 years of my life to learn but it's
like worrying doesn't solve anything it
just makes everything worse I think kind
of think there's only gonna be another
week and a half two weeks of this that's
what I think we'll see you like I said I
heard that they said to at least keep
things closed until April 24th which is
about another three weeks right if they
start losing control over certain things
that started going bad they're gonna
[ __ ] open at this point so like I
said that's I'm just kind of rolling
because this [ __ ] might go pear-shaped
in any minute when it starts going pear
shape marks mark the words of
Nostradamus they're gonna go okay [ __ ]
that everybody get back to work
that's what they're gonna do I always
like to that that's a very British turn
of phrase everything going pear shape
yeah you get you get that from [ __ ]
Salvador Dali no melting clocks and [ __ ]
just gotta [ __ ] they say that [ __ ]
pair of shoes everything goes
pear-shaped or tits up yeah all right so
have a good rest of the Wednesday
everybody stays safe healthy out there
and try not to worry about [ __ ] and
we'll be back to talk to you again
tomorrow